really happy to see you will go good to
see you so good to see everyone
yeah okay so you been how've I been yeah
I've been great right great and even
good
yeah anything new with you nope no just
you know living life and yeah yeah I
think is great with the family things
are good with your family yep that's a
look good if you lost weight you look
yeah less like five pounds yeah yeah you
you have a bird on your shoulder it's
moving out of the back of your collar
turn around you have a bird Yeah right
right yeah you have a bird on your on
your shoulder
you know Conan here's the deal I'm happy
to come on your show I'm happy to talk
about the movie
get hard I'm happy to talk about you
know anything but I don't wanna talk
about my personal life okay you know so
we're not gonna discuss we're not gonna
discuss the bird on my shoulder whatever
you want we we've known each other a
long long time and you always you're you
talk about anything now he never I
didn't know you were this you seem a
little angry no I'm not angry I'm not
angry at all but there's no reason to
bring professor feathers into any sort
of conversation professor feathers and
now I've just revealed his name and the
audience is totally uncomfortable so you
don't what you called it you said it was
gonna happen I'm sorry professor
feathers said this is going to come up
this is gonna keep you know what yeah
yeah he did
you know it doesn't matter because now
he's agitated and I'm gonna hear it on
the whole ride home okay well if we
could just leave him yeah
and now you've got a type close above
him and he hates looking at himself look
now he's finished now he's totally
spooked okay look you so you come here
and you come out with a bird on your
shoulder I knew I shouldn't have come
out here yeah no you're welcome here
anytime but you come out with a bird on
your shoulder then say we can't how much
must two not asked about a heart
relevant to anything okay it's not
relevant to anything can I just ask is
it cockatoo it looks a little like a
copy you're so dirty go for the joke
would it help if I told you yes it's a
cockatoo okay and here's a funny one
Conan he's got a he's a bear all right
that's gonna be tweeted about it's gonna
be all about social media and he just
wanted to hang out and I told him to be
low-key okay and now you've made it so
weird so he looks really mad he looks
very uncomfortable you don't even know
he is shaking he's furious he's looking
at me now he's looking at me I haven't
seen hatred like that hmm he's so mad he
hates you so you just want to keep is it
professor feathers professor feathers
impressive others you want to come out
of any discussions
that's for professor dawn feathers and
it's just something about my life I
don't like to share
okay good okay this is off-limits
off-limits well that you know a heads-up
would have been nice maybe a little you
could have told me also too I I think
just respecting our friendship and
knowing that you know I told the
producers please don't ask any questions
about the bird okay and you just you
know blazed right through that okay
well that's me you know always trying to
get got your journal is got to tourism
you got a bird on your shoulder gotcha
all right well maybe we should just take
a commercial break something I guess I
don't know
you